(audience applauds)
We want everyone to experience the magic
of New York style pizza and it is magic.
World famous in fact.
So here to show us how to make the perfect pizza at home,
is literally one of the biggest stars in the chef world,
who are rock stars, let's face it,
It's Anne Burrell.
(audience applauds and cheers)
(Jill cheers)
Hi.
Oh my god.
There is so much love in this room,
I wanna just live here.
Good come live!
I'll cook for you
every single day, if you'd like me to.
And I will be your student,
Okay. (laughs)
And I want you to drive this segment,
how can you teach us to do this?
Me and Jill, we're your girls.
Well, today I'm gonna show you guys
a little bit how to do,
and give you some tips for making a great pie at home.
So I mean,
you know, sometimes people get a little freaked out
about like, (gasp) pizza dough,
do I have to make it?
You can totally buy pizza dough at the store,
and usually it comes frozen.
(audience laughs)
So, my tip for using that kind of purchased pizza dough,
let it defrost, let it come to room temperature,
and I like sort of a thin,
a thinner sort of pizza,
so, my spring time pie that I'm doing
is,
Hashtag springtime pie (laughs)
Springtime pie, we have
asparagus,
prosciutto,
a little fontina,
so, just make sure that it's like a nice even thin layer,
you can use your fingertips to kind of push it out
a little bit and kind of stretch it,
and then make sure you preheat your oven,
so pizzas cook hard and fast at a high temperature.
Hashtag hard and fast.
Right.
Hard, high and fast,
(audience laughs)
that's how we like it.
It's day time TV.
And well, you know, a little afternoon delight dear.
And,
(audience laughs)
Hashtag afternoon delight.
if you don't,
if you're not lucky enough to have a pizza oven,
I recommend buying a pizza stone,
because that will help the dough on the bottom
create a nice crisp, crunch to your dough,
and not a (wails) not a limp dough.
So when you're going to put your toppings on your pizza,
I like a liberal coating,
so cheese is like a nice even coating,
I find of you sprinkle it from a little higher,
it's easier to get it like a
a more even coating.
And then I have some asparagus,
give those a liberal sprinkling,
and so then we would just put this into your preheated oven,
and then when it comes out of the oven,
we top it with a little bit of prosciutto,
and then we just give a little sprinky dink of the arugula
on the done pie.
Let me try this.
Yes.
Oh my god.
(audience cheers)
It's so good.
(audience applauds)
damn.
Oh my god,
Anne,
Like, it's so good.
I'm getting flavors I never get normally from pizza.
Right. The freshness of the asparagus and the arugula
is so unprecedented, the salt from the prosciutto,
I know I should chew but I can't.
(laughs)
(audience laughs)
Anne, this is amazing,
so are you,
Jill, I love you.
I love you.
And I just wanna thank Jill and Anne,
the new season
of Worst Cooks in America premiers on the Food Network
on April 25th.
(upbeat theme music)